he spent four years as news of the world
editor but Andy Coulson has always
denied that he knew anything about phone
hacking today he'll be asked again by
police if he knew or was involved in
listening to private messages I don't
suppose that Andy Coulson will be
charged immediately the police will want
to see what he has to say and want to
consider anything he can tell them in
particular about Rebekah Brooks before
they send a dossier to the Crown
Prosecution Service before a decision is
taken as to whether Andy Coulson or
Rebekah Brooks or other people are going
to be charged and if so with what labour
leader ed miliband will use a speech
today to step up the pressure on the
Prime Minister over his friendship with
Andy Coulson who resigned as his
official spokesman in January he'll say
we all now must exercise our duty to
stand up for the public without fear and
without favor I know this is difficult
for the prime minister because of his
personal relationships and because these
are very powerful forces but there are
moments in our national life when the
public looks to political leaders not
just to express sentiment but to accept
the responsibility for leading the call
for change this is such a moment he said
news international's chief executive
Rebekah Brooks left in a hurry last
night after the news of the papers
demise was announced but unlike hundreds
of staff she looks like keeping her job
there was bewilderment there was
disappointment but it wasn't any kind of
mob anger it's quite the contrary there
was a lot of quiet pride from a team of
brilliant journalist Ward winning
journalists who are very proud of the
product and very proud of 168 year
history the news the world james Murdoch
left news international last night after
sacrificing the news of the world but he
stood by Rebekah Brooks I am satisfied
that Rebecca her leadership of this
business and her standard of ethics and
her standard of conduct throughout her
career are very good if it was their own
story they'd probably call it
sensational but today's papers reflect
the fall of the news of the world after
168 years
we were sickened to the call by the
revelations that came out about Milly
Dowler and and that the troops in the
seven seven victims and now like them
we've been caught up in this awful mess
created by people who work for our paper
many years ago the Prime Minister's
association with Andy Coulson could now
prove critical Downing Street will be
hoping the former newspaper editors
story stands up to further scrutiny
today McMartin Sky News